hey what's going on everybody
i am dave rubin this is the reuben
report direct message for today may 11
2021 as always click that subscribe
button if you're watching on youtube and
tap that notification bell so that you
might
just see our videos and i am feeling
very
refreshed and alive and awake i had a
three-day weekend
we did not go live yesterday because my
brother was visiting and we ate a lot of
food and played a lot of basketball and
did a lot of
pool time and got a little bit of sun
and i'm feeling good about the world and
then of course
as i'm ready to get back into the swing
of things this morning i open up twitter
this morning
as i'm having my morning coffee and i
see a tweet
which basically from the new york times
basically
calling me a white supremacist so we're
going to have to unpack
that and much more yes that's what we're
going to focus on this morning just
more nonsense from the new york times
they also got the name of the show wrong
they called it the dave rubin show
i suspect i'm not going to get an
apology or a retraction on either i was
more annoyed actually that they called
it
the dave rubin show than the than being
called a white supremacist like that
being called a white supremacist by the
new york times
it's happened before it'll happen again
you know we realize everyone knows
they're a garbage crap factory
um but i was like at least get the name
of the show right so if people google
so if the white supremacists that are
reading the new york times are like oh
i'd like to find out more about that
white supremacist dave rubin and his
white supremacist show
they'd at least google the correct show
now they're not even going to go to the
correct show unless there's an
alternative
show named the dave rubin show where
that guy is interviewing a lot of white
supremacists
you never know you never know anyway
we're going to talk all about
that and then we are going to talk about
this clip that went viral
over the weekend from sarah silverman on
her podcast just trashing caitlyn jenner
and i think it's a perfect
example of how the wolksters are
everything that they purport everyone
else to be that they're actually the
bigots
and the intolerant ones and all that and
sarah silverman who every now and again
has this like little glimmer of like oh
you are waking up to the lefty nonsense
but then she just
always falls right back into it so we're
going to show you that clip
oh and then the third story today we're
doing four stories total the third story
today i think is really important
it's about this pastor in canada who we
referenced on the show on friday
uh we did a whole panel on what's going
on in canada and the draconian lockdowns
and everything else and ezra levant
from the rebel brought up the story of
this
pastor i believe his name is arthur
palaski and
he has been arrested for trying to keep
his
church open during the lockdowns we're
going to show you some video on that
uh it was sort of breaking as we talked
about it on friday and then of course
nothing nothing good came of that
and then finally we're going to talk
about disney because that giant
corporate conglomerate that's basically
running all of our lives they're very
woke
and they're very racist and they are
instituting that within their entire
organization right now with this
diversity inclusion nonsense
and chris ruffo who's just doing
freaking spectacular work
who i've had on the show who is a lawyer
who is doing great work exposing how
these
diversity and inclusion departments are
systemically adding racism
to all of these giant organizations well
he got some leaked documents that disney
is uh you know putting forward to their
employees and it's just
extraordinary the the evil garbage
woke crap that they are putting out
there it's just incredible but first
before we get to all of that the new
york times kind of called me a white
supremacist again
so let's unpack it so yes i woke up to a
tweet from a guy by the name of wilt
chamberlain not wilt
chamberlain will chamberlain from human
events which is an online magazine
and i've met him once or twice nice guy
and his tweet said this is the state of
the new york times apparently
mara gay she's the journalist over there
thinks the reuben report a former
jankyuger employee
is basically stormfront now i suppose
stormfront is some giant alt-right
actually kind of neo-nazi online
magazine i'm not even quite sure what
that is
but what he was quoting was this now
this is a question
that was asked by mara gay who is the
new york times
journalist this is a question that she
asked andrea now andre yang is running
for mayor of new york city and they were
doing a print
interview and she asked this question of
andre
yang thank you over the years you've
built your brand by
frequently doing radio and other
appearances with
right wing media personalities at times
you said that the democratic party
should gravitate away from identity
politics
you've supported automating fast food
workers at times
why appear on shows like the dave rubin
show
who regularly hosts white supremacists
okay so first off let's just do a little
cleanup job on that
you can see the way these wokesters
combine all of these
issues into one thing like oh you're
sort of
against identity politics and you're
kind of for
automation and scary right-wingers like
it's just like
this amalgamation of stuff that makes no
sense now as for
right wing look i've been talking for a
while how basically
defending my liberal principles is
becoming a conservative position
i did write an entire book here
defending classical liberalism defending
the liberalism that once was
the democratic party defending the
liberalism that john f kennedy
was talking about and that daniel
patrick moynihan was talking about and
that the great
uh list of true liberal thinkers
uh have been fighting for for years
including the founders of the united
states now i know that that's scary
right-wing
conservative stuff but okay so they get
the name of the show wrong that's fine
and
in essence they're saying that i
regularly have white supremacists on now
to my knowledge i have never had a white
supremacist none
have i had people on the show who've
talked about borders who've talked about
immigration
all sorts of stuff i have no belief that
i've ever ever had anyone on the show or
certainly no one who has ever said it to
me that they want
that they're a white supremacist in the
in that they want either america to be a
white nation
or that they believe that white people
should have special laws now ironically
it's the woksters
and i assume marigay is one of them who
actually wants systemic racism right
they want black people to have special
laws they want there to be quotas they
like the idea of affirmative action and
all of those things
i'm against all those things i want
everyone to be treated equally
regardless of
the color of their skin okay so that was
the question
she she says i regularly host white
supremacists which in essence is
saying that i'm a white supremacist and
uh she gets the name of the show wrong
now here's the
response from yang and you really got to
listen to it it's actually a little bit
confusing because the way he spoke
but especially the end part is the key
part first i think that the interviews
you're describing may not have done
that at the time that i appeared on
their platform
i think most people know that at the
time when i was running for president i
was willing to talk to just
about anyone that frankly would help get
the message out
about how trump was the symptom of a
whole series of problems
and that we need to unite to defeat him
and that's something that i think my
campaign did make some contribution to
i'm someone who thinks that talking to
people of different backgrounds is not
necessarily
always a bad thing but certainly my goal
was just to try and make the case to
different people who could help defeat
trump i'm not sure that was the wrong
approach
i will say too that if i had a choice
between a new york times podcast and one
of those
these podcasts that we're describing i
would have chosen you
okay so he sort of makes sense at the
beginning of this andrew yang
where he's saying basically you know you
should talk to all sorts of different
people
and if you're going to talk to different
people you're going to talk to people
that have different opinions than you
and i know that's very scary
to the wokesters but he was trying to
have a campaign that was going to reach
out to all of those disaffected people
right so that's
that's actually quite admirable now what
he's saying there at the end
now first off he's also uh he's equate
he's sort of doing a little trick there
because he's also kind of like oh
i didn't know everything about these
podcasts but in essence
i guess he's basically talking about me
but the last line there
is the interesting thing because he says
uh can we just scroll back so i can just
see a little i want to get it totally
right
he says i will say too that if i had a
choice between a new york times podcast
and one of these podcasts that we're
describing
i would have chosen you so he's saying a
couple things there so first off what
he's saying is the new york times
ignored him
and that's actually true the times and
msnbc
and mainstream media did ignore him now
the clips that we put up with andrew
yang who i treated totally respectfully
got about a million views uh so i think
he enjoyed talking to my audience and
and i
treated him with the same respect that i
treat everybody else uh so in essence
what he's saying there is oh
because you guys wouldn't put me on i
had to do those other shows now that
actually might be kind of true right
he couldn't get traction with those guys
because he isn't a purely
far left demagogue the way they would
want him to be
elizabeth warren or an aoc or a bernie
or that type of thing he was a little
bit more centrist
and that was dangerous to these guys but
what he's also saying is he's basically
throwing me
and i suppose he sort of means joe rogan
here too
uh meaning if you guys would have put me
on i wouldn't i would have chosen you
instead of those other
dangerous things now i have to say
something here and i don't like doing
this because i don't like
throwing former guests under the bus and
i'm really going to try not to do that
but i have to say something that is
absolutely true
about andrew yang when andrew yang came
to my house
he my house that's where we did the show
in my garage he walked in
we chatted for a little bit we talked a
little bit about basketball and video
games
smiling happy fun he told me how much he
loved the show
and that he understands the difference
between liberals
and what's happened with the crazy left
um he talked about how incredible
the idw the intellectual dark web was
that was in the middle of when the whole
thing was blowing up
and that we're actually making a
difference and a whole bunch of other
stuff along those lines
so if he thought somehow that i was a
white supremacist or that i host white
supremacists
or anything else he didn't say anything
about that all he talked about was how
great the show is and that i'm making a
difference
and that liberalism is worthy of being
saved and everything else
so i don't think that's throwing andre
yang under the bus the way he just threw
me under the bus
but i think that's addressing what the
actual truth is by the way i reached out
to andre yang first thing this morning
about four hours ago privately
didn't hear back now he could be very
busy he's running for mayor of new york
city right now we also reached out to
his press team
and we didn't hear back um so anyway i
mention all of this
not really not even to make it about me
but this when people say to me well dave
what's happened to the liberals it seems
to me that yang is sort of a perfect
example of that
he's someone who has good i would say
old school liberal
ideals but he really wants to play
to the woksters and i wouldn't have done
that scary dave rubin show i would have
done your podcast i don't know that
anyone listens
to a new york times podcast millions of
people watch and listen to this show
right we've
we've actually made a difference here um
but he is
pandering because he's running uh for
mayor of new york city right now and he
has to do what he has to do so he has to
throw people under the bus
including scary me and i know i'm i'm a
scary guy and
yes the new york times did run a front
page cover story about how i'm leading
people to the alt-right
even though you know i grew up around
holocaust survivors i write about that
in my book defending liberalism
and i'm completely against that identity
politics and i'm completely for
individual rights and all that stuff but
i know it's very scary
but when i when i see why now
people don't like liberals i get it i
fully get it
because this is what liberals tend to do
liberals tend to gatekeep to the point
that they'll throw anyone under the bus
in order to save themselves and that's
what he's trying to do
andrew yang knows that i haven't had
white supremacists on the show that
isn't to say i haven't had controversial
people on the show
but he knows i haven't had white
supremacists he knows that i did the
right thing by having him on the show
and then i treated him the way everybody
else did
so i don't really want it look she's
just a bad journalist
this mara gay person you got the name of
the show wrong like at the very least if
the new york times is a place of
journalism
at the very least you would fix that if
not you know saying that i'm not a white
supremacist or that i don't host white
supremacists
but everyone's a white supremacist to
these people and by the way i had a ton
of people on twitter telling me today
you know sue them for libel sue them for
libel and i've been through this game
before you know the funny thing is when
i woke up and i saw this this morning i
actually kind of smiled
because i was like oh here we go again
like this is the stuff that after you've
been through the hit pieces enough and
and after you've been around enough
people who've been through this stuff i
saw it happen to jordan peterson all the
time
and you guys you guys know all this
stuff all the people that go called
racists and
bigots and everything else the stuff
that they call you right we happen to be
public people so you see them doing it
to us but really what they're doing is
they're doing it to you i mean this is
what i always tell you about tucker
the reason they're always saying these
horrible things about tucker is his
because tucker's actually
fighting for you guys right like he's
fighting for himself but in essence he's
fighting
for all the rest of us and they want to
destroy him so when they're saying
tucker is a white supremacist
because he either believes in borders or
whatever it is that he might believe in
it's like they're really coming for all
of you so i saw this this morning and it
wasn't like
like back in the day that five years ago
or something that really would have
upset me it's not nice to be called a
white supremacist when you're not a
white supremacist i suppose if you are a
white supremacist and someone calls you
a white supremacist it's a pretty
pretty great day you're like oh i got
the credit i deserve
um but i'm not a white supremacist so
when they say these ridiculous things
the new york times is saying far more
about itself mara gay
is saying far more about herself her her
myopic view of the world than anything
about me like i'm not a white
supremacist there you go
i don't believe that white people should
have special rights or or an ethno state
here in the united states i don't mean
to be controversial but that's not the
stuff
that i believe in i believe this is a
country for everybody i believe that's
stuff that's on the
statue of liberty there and i believe in
the founding documents now the problem
is the people at the new york times
and and i suspect this woman they don't
believe in those things they believe
that the founding documents
the reason for the united states they
believe that is evil that's why they did
the 1619 project right because the roots
of this country are racist
according to these these people and by
the way these are the ones as i always
say that are ushering in
systemic racism because we now even know
that the covid relief bill
has certain benefits that you get
depending on the color of your skin yes
really that is real i am not making that
up anywho i could probably go on
about this all day long but for those of
you
that are sitting here thinking wait a
minute marigay wha why is that ring a
bell
why does that name ring a bell you may
remember this video from a few months
ago
that went viral you see it as a
possibility if he wants to spend a
billion bucks
beating this guy he could do it
absolutely
um somebody tweeted recently that um
actually with the money he spent he
could have given every american
a million dollars got it let's put it up
on the screen it when i
read it uh tonight on social media it
kind of all became clear
bloomberg spent 500 million on ads u.s
population 327
million uh don't tell us if you're ahead
of us on the math he could have given
each american
one million dollars and have had lunch
money left over
it's an incredible way of putting it
it's an incredible way
of putting it it's true it's disturbing
it does
it does suggest you know what we're
talking about here which is there's too
much money in politics
i mean is that is that just perfect did
you catch what happened there i don't
know if that's worth
worse for mara gay or worse for brian
williams but bloomberg put 500 million
in that ridiculous
fake campaign that he ran and they were
claiming that he could have given a
million
dollars to every american for that um
for that amount of money
uh that would have cost we even did the
math using our fancy iphone calculator
uh if you gave every american 1 million
dollars
um because there's about 328
million americans that would have been
328 trillion dollars
not 500 million dollars so she's not
that bright
i get it about math i'm being a little
petty here brian williams these people
are
all embarrassing like the reason that
clip the reason i even posted that clip
because it's just such a perfect example
of drivel
new york times journalist new york times
journalist
goes on msnbc journalist program
with brian williams who has disgraced
brian williams who got caught lying
while he was the anchor on nbc so they
booted him to the minor leagues to msnbc
so they were like you're not a
journalist worthy of this place we'll
put you on our crap channel over here
you know so you can hang out with maddow
and uh and they get everything wrong
like did anyone get fired the segment
producer
like anyone involved in the math or the
production of that segment or anything
like it's just it's all just
silly nonsense anyway to put the button
on this i am not a white supremacist the
name of the show is the reuben report
and i will continue telling you to the
best of my ability what's going on in
the world and uh
i enjoy those of you who enjoy it oh and
one last thing
in honor of mara gay and the new york
times and the dave rubin show and the
whole freaking thing
if you sign up today at reubenreport.com
support if you sign up today
for the reuben report community will
give you three months free
that's what we're going to do if you
want to sign up to this white supremacy
show
reubenreport.com support you're going to
get three months free
on the annual subscription so it's 45
instead of 60 bucks
and i think you'll find we have an
incredible growing community of free
thinkers and people debating ideas
and talking about stuff and making
social media fun and
and not painful so it's reubenreport.com
support
three months free that is only for today
and now we'll get to everything else but
before i do i want to talk to you about
start mail
you know free email services like gmail
and yahoo aren't really free of course
you guys know that you pay with your
privacy
and since those companies have access to
every email you send and receive big
tech can sell your data to the highest
bidder
from business plans to medical records
companies can sell your personal data
to target you with intrusive ads and
open you up to identity theft and
phishing attacks
that's why start mail wants to secure
your email and make you feel safe again
start mail keeps your email private
period every email is encrypted
even if the recipient doesn't use
encryption which means that big tech
can't scan read analyze or sell your
personal data
ever start mail also prevents government
agencies from spying on you
like in dragnet operations with start
mail deleted means deleted when you
delete an email it's gone forever
and start mail uses their own servers
not amazon's which means they can't be
put out of business like parlor
start mail is also backed by the most
stringent privacy laws in the world
you'll get
unlimited anonymous aliases this feature
protects your main email address from
spam and phishing attacks
so when you're giving your email to a
company but you want to protect your
identity
start mail can generate a shareable
alias email so people can't sell your
info
and they can be deleted anytime here at
the reuben report we've been looking for
alternatives to google so we're excited
by what start mail has to offer i don't
trust big tech and either should you
start securing your email privacy with
start mail sign up today and you'll get
fifty percent off the first year
go to start mail.com slash ruben that's
start with a t
mail.com ruben for 50 off your first
year start mail.com
reuben starbelldesk.com ruben and now
back to me
so sarah silverman she's a comedian i i
sort of have to say comedian the way i
have to say journalist
these days mostly she's a shrieking
harping
preening progressive wokester but she's
got a podcast
uh and as i said to you at the beginning
of the show you know she's one of these
people that like she used to be
politically incorrect and do blackface
and date jimmy kimmel who did blackface
and every you know make fun of gay
people and make fun of
everybody but then she sort of became
woke and politically correct
and now she's constantly you know
basically saying everyone else
is a racist and all that stuff which
always is a cover for their own sins
right
i mean we we know this this is what they
all do this is sort of like hank azaria
uh who does the voice of apu in the
simpsons he's not going to do apu
anymore
uh but he's not returning the money so
they're always protecting
what they've done jimmy kimmel the
reason he calls everyone else racist
it's because it's like yeah you were
doing carl malone in blackface because
you're a racist jimmy kimmel well sarah
silverman on her podcast
went on this crazy rant about caitlyn
jenner
and let's take a listen if you think a
trans girl
what you think a trans girl is too
strong i
what about tall girls as opposed to
short girls
what about a boys in high school who are
teeny tiny and their
teammates uh have already hit puberty
and are shaving
why don't you just have co-ed sports
divided by weight or height
i you know this is so dumb they are
legislating this
without one single example of how this
plays out
this is not worrying about girls sports
uh
believe me not i think
there are better ways to worry about
girl sports
this is not worrying about this is not
what that is this is not worrying this
is not concern for girls sports it's
transphobia full stop
it's just such a bummer when a you know
such a prominent trans woman is such a
[ __ ]
you know it's like being jewish right
now and
having the most recognizable jewish
names be weinstein and epstein you know
it's like
super not awesome but yeah well listen
as a jew frankly i'm not thrilled with
uh people named silverman but putting
that aside for a second
what you're really understanding about
these people first off how do you listen
to that how does anyone watch that show
or listen to her i mean it's just
there's such an unpleasant
way of speaking and just like this
certitude about stuff that she doesn't
know what she's talking about
so first off all caitlyn wants and all
that most
sane people want is you don't want
biological boys
competing with biological girls in
sports
everyone knows that there's a difference
between boys and girls we've been
through this [ __ ] so many times
that it's actually getting annoying and
in a weird way as i've been saying
they've sort of won like the movement
has won
because they keep us all talking about
something that affects
virtually nobody not to say for the
people that it affects it isn't
important
but it's it's just nonsense so first off
she's also then making this comparison
that the trans thing is somehow like
tall girls competing with short girls or
something like that which is crazy
because if you think about basketball
for a second
if you're very tall you have an
advantage and if you're short you have
to play differently but a team needs a
point guard who's usually short i needed
a center who's usually tall
and this is how you do it but those
people have the same biological
characteristics right
like some of them happen to be taller
but they do that's not changing
muscle and bone density and all of these
things that are biological
so if you if if what they're really
saying if what someone like sarah
silverman is really saying is that we're
all just
actually evil uh evil and that is what
she's saying in a way
if you if that were all just equal
meaning boy male and female they mean
nothing biological differences mean
nothing well then she's really making
the best argument to get
rid of gendered sports altogether that
we should have
just one league now i think there's an
argument to be made for that
however i don't think the feminists or
any girl
is going to want that because all of the
sports and sports are based on skill
right and your ability to accomplish
your ability to kick the ball in the net
or
dunk the basketball or hit the baseball
they will all be dominated by men which
is why
we all know that the worst player in the
nba would be
the wnba mvp that doesn't mean you can't
like watching girls basketball it
doesn't mean that girls
shouldn't play basketball my my producer
michael his sister is awesome at
basketball she came here
and whooped my ass in horse it was
embarrassing
she even turned him in the middle and
she's like can i beat him this badly
i was like yeah you can because but i
was trying okay and yes i'm 44 i got a
torn acl yeah okay fine
the point is that's not to say women
suck at sports they don't but but
men and women are different men and
women are different the idea
that saying that makes you transphobic
and also the word phobic
that you have an irrational fear of
trans people it seems to me
that sarah silverman is transphobic she
has an irrational fear of these people
because when caitlyn jenner comes out
and says what she believes
you think you can say all the worst
things about her right you can call her
a [ __ ]
and i'm sure she's called her worse
right but i believe the trans people
have
the same ability as everybody else to
believe all sorts of different things
i believe black people can think
whatever they want and that inherently
doesn't make them a bad person
right i believe trans people can think
all the things that they want but this
woman
caitlyn jenner who i don't i personally
don't have a problem calling a woman
right that is not denying that she is
still biologically a male which i'm
fairly certain caitlyn
would say as well when when four years
ago when she first sort of came out as
trans she was a hero to all of these
people
but then she did the cardinal sin of
wokism
she dared start saying what she actually
believes
and now she is the enemy so it is you
sarah silverman who is transphobic
because you are phobic you have an
irrational fear of trans people
who think for themselves because guess
what sarah silverman not all trans
people
have to think the way you think they
have to think thus
you are the bigot in this case lori lori
and of course you know her ex-boyfriend
she's done blackface i'm pretty sure
and her ex-boyfriend jimmy kimmel has
done blackface and
you know i guess you know they're racist
it's just by the rules that they've set
up these are racist people
comedy has no bearing on any of it and
they're racists and bigots and
and sexist and if you don't believe that
jimmy kimmel's a sexist well
you better check some of those old clips
in the of the man show because boy all
the girls jumping on trampolines and
all the comments about boobs and blondes
and all that stuff i mean that kimmel
guy
and again that's why he has to
constantly
bow to wokism because he knows he's a
bad guy actually he did bad stuff
in the past so he has to bow to his new
leader
all right let's let's move on uh i
wanted to cover this story because i
think this is really important you know
we did this panel
show on friday all all about what's
going on in canada and
there's huge problems in canada they
have draconian lockdowns
they have rules being changed constantly
they have police setting up
barricades stopping people on roads
asking for identification i mean it
genuinely sounds like nazi type stuff
and we actually
talked about it using that phrase on the
show and i
i don't think it is too much of a
jump you know in this weird world that
we live in right now where you can just
call anyone a nazi and you can call
anyone a white supremacist
and make up the name of their show and
all of those things um
the idea that these people the
authorities in canada are now using
nazi-like tactics i think is fine show
me your papers right
like stopping people like how does it
start it didn't just start
one day where the nazis were just there
and it was just like kill all the jews
right it just wasn't that
it was this slow creep so the things
that are happening in canada right now
feel like that slow creep that's what we
did a panel on on friday
an ezreal event from rebel media who's
been one of the
the prime guys showing some of the
videos exposing some of this nonsense
um he was on the show and he mentioned
that there is a
pastor in canada his name is arthur
palaski
and uh he was about to be arrested now
he
this guy there i think we had played a
video of his a couple weeks ago
where there were people trying to come
into his church authorities trying to
come into the church
and is he polish i think he's polish
originally can we check on that
um certainly he's from eastern europe
originally and he dealt with communists
right
he dealt with socialists he dealt with
bad people and he
as the police are coming into his church
he's yelling at them you're not welcome
here you nazis you can't come in here
this is a guy who's lived
through this well he's just been
arrested so we've got a so ezreal event
tweeted this and then we're going to
show you some video
a heavily armed swat team just took down
a christian pastor
heading home from church police say he's
charged with
inciting people to go to church this is
the second
pastor jailed this year we're
crowdfunding
for his lawyers at savearter.com that's
s-a-v-e-a-r-t-u-r
dot com and we link to it on friday uh
now we've got some video from rebel news
hello friends this is pastor art
polowsky if you're watching this video
that means
they have successfully arrested me and i
am in
jail if you would like to support me if
you like to support rebel news
and the legal team that is trying their
best to get me out of this trouble
please go to safearthur.com
please donate please help help me help
my family help my
wife and my children to get me out of
this horrible
illegal situation please go to
safearthur.com
and get me out of this if you can okay
so to be clear again
and you can find the the original video
as well
he was arrested because he allowed
people to go into his church and they
did not want that to happen and he
kicked the police out so they knew that
this was coming because he then wanted
to keep his church open
there's no evidence that anyone got sick
at his church or anything like that
just for a little background on him i i
was correct he was born
in poland he then lived in greece and
eventually immigrated to canada in 1995
and became a canadian citizen
in 2004. i suspect when he moved to
canada
you know 26 years ago or so that he did
not
anticipate being arrested for trying to
hold church services
in canada okay so this is this is an
important story you're not going to see
this on mainstream media i felt we had
to cover it
again and it's it's save arter
a-r-t-u-r-dot-com
if you want to donate and help his legal
fund and
what's happening what's happening in
canada why why are they just folding
over why is this happening why is no one
talking about it
you tell me i don't know what the answer
to that is uh finally guys i want to do
one other story
um because this broke yesterday chris
ruffo who i've had on the show i've
mentioned to you guys
he's one of these people you know i
don't like people that just
talk there's a lot of people that just
talk but don't actually do anything
i try in my own life to be someone
that's doing something as well that's
why i started locals.com to fight
to fight some of the big tech stuff i
try to bring people on the show
who are actually doing things like
fighting back in whatever
way that they can which is why i had the
teacher on from grace church school
a couple weeks ago and that way anyone
that that if you're under assault and
you're out there
i want to have you on to amplify your
story because it can't just be
about talking about things it's about
doing things well chris ruffo is doing a
great job of
using the legal system to expose
how diversity and inclusion is bringing
systemic racism into so many
of our corporate structures and our
government so i've got a tweet
from chris this is from yesterday
exposing what's going on at disney and
i would say you're not going to believe
it but yeah of course you're going to
believe it the walt disney corporation
claims that america was founded on
systemic racism
encourages employees to complete a white
privilege
checklist and separates minorities into
racially segregated affinity groups
i've obtained internal documents that
will shock you okay so we're going to
show you some of the internal documents
right now and i'm going to just read
some of the highlights from these things
so these are actual confirmed internal
documents
from disney chris ruffo has put his his
name and his reputation on the line i
have absolute faith in this guy
and here we go so take a look at some of
the docs according to a trove of
whistleblower materials disney has
launched a diversity and inclusion
program
called reimagine tomorrow which includes
trainings on systemic racism white
privilege
white fragility white saviors
microaggressions
and anti-racism we'll continue disney
claims that america has a long history
of systemic racism and transphobia
and tells employees they must take
ownership of educating yourself
about structural anti-black racism and
not rely on your black colleagues to
educate you which is emotionally taxing
i mean it gets even crazier white
employees are told to work through
feelings of guilt
shame and defensiveness to understand
what is beneath them
and what needs to be healed they must
listen with
empathy to black colleagues and not
question or debate
black colleagues lived experience i mean
is this stuffed bananas
disney tells employees that they should
reject equality
or equal treatment and instead strive
for equity
or the equality of outcome they mess
they must
reflect on america's racist
infrastructure
and think carefully about whether or not
their wealth
is derived from racism i mean there's
more this is just insane
disney sponsored the creation of a
21-day racial
equity and social justice challenge
and recommended it to employees the
challenge begins with a lesson on
systemic racism and tells participants
they have all been raised
in a society that elevates white culture
over
others i mean this stuff is just
absolutely evil disney is a
giant corporate conglomerate that is in
charge of
so much of our cultural information
so much of the stuff that makes america
america right
the disney movies the star wars movies
they buy everything they control so much
of the way we think about things
and at this point if if you go to disney
things and you
go to their parks and you buy star wars
toys they wreck star wars too
i think you've heard me talk about that
once or twice but you are paying
for the people who are trying to destroy
you it is as simple as that i think rufo
also had a tweet a follow-up on that
about the top three guys at disney who
are all of course white heterosexual
straight men strange they didn't let a
black guy
jump in there if they really cared about
any of this stuff these people are all
hypocrites and these these institutions
must fail and i don't think they can be
saved i don't think any of these things
can be saved our cultural or political
institutions anymore we must
build new things i don't i guess we have
to have some sort of national
separation like these things are just
going down
with the ship hopefully disney will
address some of this stuff and if disney
doesn't want
systemic racism then they should come
out against the covid bill which helped
black farmers more than it helped white
farmers so systemic racism is here
courtesy of the democrats courtesy of
the progressives and the woksters
right if disney wants to get rid of
systemic racism then maybe they want to
get rid of affirmative action
because i don't think helping people
based on the color of their skin giving
government services based on the color
of skin
actually help well it doesn't help
anybody and we know it keeps people
actually in the cycle of poverty
and if you don't believe that show me
show me where when affirmative action
comes in and subsidized housing comes in
show me all the success stories of when
people escape these things please
please show me and you know what you
can't try a little thomas soul might
help you
uh guys part two of my interview with
senator josh hawley
from missouri is up right now we talk a
ton it's mostly about
big tech and we get into all of the
philosophical issues
that i'm constantly talking about on the
show related to free markets related
to uh related to competition related to
regulation related to breaking these
things up
and can we send bureaucrats to go into
google and fiddle around with the
algorithms and make everything more fair
or is that just a complete pipe dream
so it's a really interesting interview
and the full episode of course is up
already
completely ad free at
reubenreport.locals.com
by the way we are doing a q a we always
do
the ask me anything q a is right here on
thursdays i'm taking questions for it
today because i'm doing a little
traveling
going to dallas later in the week so if
you want to submit questions
for that q a you can submit at
reubenreport.locals.com
and then friday we're doing a panel uh
with uh three people travis brown
and my former guests and friends douglas
murray and peter bogosian travis is a
filmmaker
and he is working on a film right now
that is soon to be released
uh all about sort of wokism and just
all the stuff all the stuff so we're
going to talk all about that
and you guys know how i feel about
douglas and peter so i'm looking forward
to that
a lot going on as i said doing a bunch
of stuff with the blaze i'll be there
all day friday filming all their shows
and anyway i hope you've enjoyed
uh the dave rubin show for today and
i'm dave rubin i'm not a white
supremacist and i don't
like white supremacists or hosting white
supremacists
andrew yang or someone from andrew
yang's team if you're watching um
i'd love to engage with you on this i
think the way i talked about
our experience together was respectful
and i would like to continue that
conversation i think you kind of
threw me under the bus there i'm a
little surprised because of all the nice
things
that you said that i was doing and the
problems that you saw with the left and
and what was happening
with liberalism sort of being destroyed
by the wokesters and you were so
impressed by the
idw and all that so your response was a
little bit odd
i don't know if you're also kind of
throwing rogan under the bus there but
if you want to clarify any of that i'd
i'd be happy to have you on completely
unedited
no papers no nothing and uh and mara gay
you know if if you're watching
maybe you want a retraction i i'm not a
white supremacist i don't regularly host
white supremacists neither one of you
guys are white supremacists right
okay no they both shift their head no so
there's no white supremacists in here
and at the very least i would assume as
a journalist you would want to correct
the name of the show so i look forward
to that
i will retweet you for a couple likes if
you do it
anyway have a great day everybody we're
back in studio tomorrow
and good luck out there it's wacky okay
see ya
you